[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that the ceo of google
sundar picai was born in india and did
you know that the ceo of microsoft satya
nadella was also born in india and guess
where the ceo of adobe was born that's
right you guessed it santanu narayan was
born in india too
say it loud say it proud india is taking
over silicon valley
in fact you could say india is taking
over the software industry worldwide
for example what is the biggest it
services company you might think of
accenture right you guessed wrong it's
tcs
an indian company and yes i know what
you're thinking right now
india isn't it a developing country that
is indeed true
two-thirds of indians live below the
poverty line and 73 million citizens
live in extreme poverty
68 million people live in slums and only
8.15
of indians are college-educated compared
to 34
of us citizens who have had college
degrees in fact 25
of indians are not even literate
nevertheless we can say there are two
india's there is the poor india that we
know about and within that
there is tech india if that was a
country on its own it would be a country
as wealthy as germany its gdp would be
177 billion u.s dollars and its
population would be the 4
million people directly employed by it
four companies tcs infosys hcl
and ypro hire over a million employees
by the way
these four companies were all born in
india if you happen to work in the it
industry i'm sure you've worked with
indians at some point there is almost
no company on this planet that hasn't
outsourced some service to india and
indian software programmers are so
appreciated that many fly to silicon
valley ending up in top positions like
ceo now i know your head is about to
explode with so many questions
how did such a poor country with so many
educational problems
become the largest actually the second
largest software exporter
worldwide today we're going to answer
this question but before we do
as always let's take a look back at some
history
[Music]
right idea wrong pass many of you might
associate india with mahatma gandhi but
the truth is that gandhi
was assassinated in 1948 before india
even passed its constitution
in fact one of the most important
figures in india's history is not gandhi
or at least not the gandhi that you
studied at school in fact our story
starts with jawaharlal
nehru
the first prime minister of india under
his government india adopted its
constitution and became an independent
country in its own rights
but nuru had a clear mission he wanted
to turn the former british colony into a
pioneer in computer manufacturing
back then computers were just becoming a
thing and there was a window of
opportunity for a newcomer to compete
with the west
the question was how do you do that
instead of following the british model
nehru took inspiration from stalin's
playbook
[Music]
this is not to say india became a
communist country but they did take many
communist elements
two in particular five-year planning and
banning imports yes the way india wanted
to nurture local industries was by
protecting them from local competitors
this is how
national baimos were created nurtured by
the states the most important one is
india's most famous conglomerate
tata yes you might know tata for their
cars but they also launched india's
first airline and the first indian
computing company
tata computer services or tcs
[Music]
at the same time the government invested
heavily in education this is how in the
1960s
india built lots of technology
universities all across the country
these are the so called indian
institutes of technology or iits
all of a sudden lots of young indians
were fully prepared to work in the
emerging computer
industry the problem there were no
companies to work for aside from tata
almost no local companies
had been created having banned most of
the technological imports local
manufacturers couldn't find things like
quality wires or sockets so in the 1970s
india had only around 150 computers
across the entire country and those were
imported by ibm who had managed to
bypass the already heavy regulations of
the indian market
this is the moment where the second
protagonist of our history comes into
the picture gandhi
but no we are not talking about the
gandhi that you know we are talking
about indira gandhi
prime minister of india during the 60s
and the 70s and no
she was not the daughter of mahatma nor
did she have any family connection
with him in fact she was the daughter of
the first protagonist mr nehru indira
gandhi realized that the only computers
in india were imported by a foreign
company so what did she do following her
father's logic she said a foreign
company has made it into our market
no way this means our regulations are
not strict enough
so in 1973 she passed the foreign
exchange regulation act making computer
imports
almost impossible
the outcome was that ibm withdrew from
the indian market that very same year
and now you might think
oh that would be good news for the local
manufacturers now they had free reign
didn't they the opposite was true
computers disappeared from the country
in the end that window of opportunity
was closed
and the rest of the world was already
too busy buying us
or japanese computers but things changed
in 1982 let's have a look
[Music]
learning from their mistakes 1982 is
remembered in india as the year when the
country hosted the asian games
something like the olympics but just for
asia the organizer of these games was
none other than
again gandhi
but this time it wasn't the gandhi that
you know nor the one that you just met
[Music]
this time it was rajiv gandhi again he
had no family ties with mahatma but he
was the son
of indira gandhi as you can see this
indian story is pretty much a family
business but this gandhi was very
different from his mother he really
understood technology and wanted to use
computers for the asian games
computers for the game schedules records
results announcements
etc and this is when he realized the
whole country had almost no computers
this was a whole epiphany for him so as
soon as he became the prime minister he
made a 180 degree shift in india's
industrial policy
the first thing he did as soon as he
took office was to remove
from one day to the next all the tariffs
and bans on imports
all of a sudden computers could be
imported duty-free as long as they were
used for developing software because
tech savvy as this gandhi was
he knew it was too late to become a
leader in computer manufacturing but
there was still a window of opportunity
to jump into the next revolution
the software revolution and oh boy the
outcomes of these new policies had
immediate effects
are you tired of paying six-figure
salaries to your american software
programmers welcome to
tech india state-of-the-art universities
highly skilled workers and all of this
for just 20
of an american salary this is only
possible in fact
india zero duties for importing
computers you don't even need to partner
with any local company to set up an
office here oh
and we even built a satellite so you can
easily communicate between your north
american headquarters and your indian
outsource office
there are tax breaks available consult
your local indian accountant for more
information
join the tech india revolution thank
india compaq has just done it so has
texas instruments even
ibm has made a great comeback to our
market everyone saves in
kenya call 1600 tech india now
suddenly india went from having less
than 1 000 computers in 1978 to having
over 80
000 in 1990 local companies like tata
computer services or hindustan computers
became outsourcing partners to big u.s
firms like hewlett-packard and the
government
was more than happy even before many
western nations india pioneered
electronic voting machines
computerized banking and even
computerized railway bookings and the
whole world was looking at india as the
go-to place for programmers
the computer revolution comes to india
sort of christian science monitor
around the same time the national
association of software and service
companies
nascom was created this is the trade
association for tech india since then
they have been the biggest lobbying
power to liberalize india's software
industry and
i know what you're going to say now come
on josh was it that
easy they just liberalized the market
and international companies came running
well there was a small trick here
remember those indian i.t
universities remember all those scholars
that didn't have it companies to work at
most of them got hired by silicon valley
they were very well trained back in
india so very soon they started gaining
more and more influence within the us
companies these indian americans
helped the indian government to craft
legislation that met the exact needs of
it companies and they also convinced
their us managers to choose
india instead of other countries this
explains for example
why india was so keen to build those
satellites to connect indian offices
with their american or british
headquarters
something that no one outside the it
industry would have thought of and this
created a virtuous cycle for the indian
i.t
industry even the financial crisis of
the 90s when the indian currency
devalued like crazy
served the interest of tech india
[Music]
sure the rest of the economy suffered
from inflation but the software
companies became even more competitive
because the indian currency was so weak
so by the year 2000 the indian software
industry was already worth over five
billion dollars but there is another
turning point in our story
something that made this india within
india even more important
worldwide and that was
the year 2000 problem those watching
this video who are over 30 might
remember this story do you remember the
year 2000 problem in india they know it
as the y2k 2000 problem back then
many experts warned about the end of the
world as we know it but what was it all
about
a senate panel describes y2k the year
computer bug as a worldwide crisis
and one of the most serious and
potentially devastating events this
nation has ever encountered
you see early computers didn't have much
storage capacity so
software developers use the last two
digits to represent the year for example
60 for 1960 and so on this means that
zero
zero would represent both 1900 and 2000.
so once the calendar clicked over to the
first of january 2000
there could be a system breakdown
at this point you're probably wondering
but how could this software nightmare
turn out to be a boon for india well
listen up
as we told you already computerization
had gained momentum in india
only in the 1980s many of the computers
were newer and did not face the y2k
bug but developed countries such as
japan south korea the us the uk
australia etc would be impacted i.t
workers had the tedious task of trawling
through millions of lines of code to
correct the fault and who was going to
do this well the city of hyderabad in
south india provided skilled i.t workers
for the task of debugging computers
india had the software manpower to race
against time and solve this problem
before the turn of the millennium
boom time in india as the millennium bug
bites
the guardian how did all of this come
together well there were a few different
factors
firstly at the time india was producing
100 000 new engineering graduates every
year and the salary of indian
programmers was about a sixth of what
their counterparts in the us earned but
also do you remember nascom
tech india trade organization they were
ready to send all their salesforce to
any trade show from luxembourg to oslo
from new york to san jose to give you an
idea in 1998 the millennium bug itself
represented 40 percent of tech india's
income
that year in other words the millennium
bug helped india position itself
as a leading software exporter over the
next decade in the 2000s
it outsourcing expanded to high-end work
such as r
d architecture and business integration
global corporations have set up
offshoring centres in india for business
strategizing and end-to-end solutions
business processing outsourcing or bpos
provide services related to customer
interaction medical transcription
insurance claim processing and more in
the last decade from 2009
to 2019 the it sector in india has
employed an additional 2 million people
and created
10 000 new technology companies to
become the 177 billion dollar industry
that it is today
wait a minute because this is where our
fairy tale ends
now let's see the darker side of the
story
[Music]
a tale of two india's there is another
thing
india is infamous for their caste system
class matters in india and it
is the best showcase for this we told
you the story of tech india a rich
country within a poor one so what
happens to the rest of india
surprisingly enough
whilst indian programmers conquer the
world less than 10 percent of indians
have internet access
in rural india only three percent have
internet at home
[Music]
for sure working in an it in india is
great a software developer can start
with a salary of just under 10
000 usd a year this doesn't sound like a
great wage by western standards but
remember this
is still india according to
xbatistan.com if you live in a city like
bangalore you can rent a flat for less
than 200
a month so yes it workers have a good
life the so-called bangalore corridor
alone has more than 67 thousand
companies and that includes indian
behemoths such as infosys
mind tree and wipro but entering tech
india requires a high level of education
proficiency in english and social
capital which is unattainable for most
indians
being a programmer is the ultimate
indian dream it's not just about getting
a good job in cities like bangalore or
mumbai it's also the prospect of being
hired overseas
the whole world is willing to hire
indian workers
japan is desperate for indian techies
but will they bite
zidine german visa offer fails to tempt
india's i.t
experts the guardian in silicon valley
50 of the migrant workers those who take
the famous h-1b
visa are indian the same happens in
seattle where amazon and microsoft have
their headquarters but even there the
indian cast system prevails
according to equality labs us
multinationals such as facebook
amazon or microsoft are discriminating
against indians from lower castes but
still
the dream for most indians is to get one
of those tech titles
to leave normal india and get into tech
india
my ticket out the indian village where
every family has an engineer the
guardian
for example in the village of patwatoli
in northern india the community has come
together to provide resources and
facilities so kids can aspire to study
in one of those indian universities
parents put together their life savings
and take out loans to provide their
children tutoring to clear the entrance
exams in 2017 alone 20 students from
this village got accepted
to one of these indian technological
universities but still
lower castes made up only nine percent
of the total faculty at the iits
so what happens in the rest of india why
aren't they growing as much as tech
india the truth is
that aside from computers india is still
a deeply protectionist country and the
paradise of bureaucracy according to the
east of doing business index india ranks
next to saudi arabia or ukraine
for example every product has a
different tax sometimes even different
models of the same product have a
different vat tax
and there are market barriers even
within the country if you pass between
two indian states you will find
long lines of trucks with merchandise
this is because each of them has to go
through internal customs control and
they have to do it several times whilst
crossing the country and what about
tariffs whilst computers
are duty-free the rest of the products
from pharmaceuticals to clothes have
some of the world's highest
tariffs and narendra modi's far
right-wing government is not making
things easier in fact the opposite is
true
india plans extra tariffs trade barriers
on 300 imported products
reuters in the last two years amazon and
walmart have become the target of
narendra modi's anger just like the
gandhis did with ibm modi is making the
situation
harder and harder for these companies
they are even debating whether to ban
e-commerce entirely from the indian
market
at the time of making this video this is
what is happening in india
confederation of all india traders wants
seven day ban on amazon for violating
country of origin rule
business today so now the question is
why doesn't india just extend the rules
for the software industry to the rest of
the economy or maybe this it boom is a
bubble that is bound to burst
tell us your thoughts in the comments so
i really hope you enjoyed this video
please hit like if you did and don't
forget to subscribe for brand new videos
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and also this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on the platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always i'll see you
in the next video and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there